Hello and good
morning, everybody.
My name is Yigit Boyar.
I'm a member of the
[? architecture ?]
team in Android.
But today, we'll talk
about Android architecture.
And mostly about
next billion users.
That's what NBU stands for.
So what happens when you develop
an application is usually,
you live in the United States,
or you live in these developed
parts of the world.
And this is your main user base.
Internet is good or reliable.
All the new stuff
comes up there.
And then you're like, oh,
I'm doing my job really well.
My application works very well.
I'm a good developer.
But that's not actually true.
Most of the world cannot
use your application,
or they don't have
a good experience.
And when I say
most of the world,
it's 78% of the
world population.
That's huge.
Four our of five people cannot
have a good experience with
your application.
Why?
Because the
circumstances you test
your application is so different
than what they actually
observe.
So today, we'll try to talk
about how do we close this gap?
What are the things that
we should pay attention
to make this a lot better.
So this is from the
International Communication
Union numbers.
In the year 2000,
most of the world
was in the developed countries.
Like 75% of internet users
from developed countries.
There was only 25% from
these developing countries,
and they were not
buying enough purchases,
[? or ?] [? you ?] would
mostly ignore them.
Well, [? there was, ?] I guess,
more [INAUDIBLE] [? person ?]
in the year 2000.
But you got the point.
By the year 2015, there are
3.2 billion internet users,
and most of them are in
these developing countries.
So if you ignore
these people, you're
actually ignoring the
key chunk of user base.
You're ignoring your future.
If you want to be
successful, your application
needs to work very
well for these users.
This is very important.
This is the future.
And you may think,
this is another number.
How many people have
broadband subscription
in developed countries?
It's 90%.
Like, almost all
of us have internet
connection on our
phones if you're living
in one of these countries.
But if you go into developing
countries, it's 40% of people.
Like half of the
people don't have
mobile broadband subscription.
And even if they do, most
of these people keep it off.
If you've been to India, and
like other parts of the world,
people are very, very careful
about their data, and only 40%
has it anyway.
But you might think about, hey,
the mobile internet is first.
When they have, and they
want to use my application,
it will still work very well.
Now let's look at some
other numbers to prove this.
So overall in the world, the 3G
coverage by population is 69%.
This is a very good number.
Like 70% of the world population
has 3G coverage in their area.
That's very good
internet by any means.
But if you look at the
rural population, it's 30%.
So if you're not
living in a city,
there's a 30% chance that
your area has 3G coverage.
And [? was ?] below 3G.
We're talking about, like, Edge.
So if you look at
urban population,
so if you look in a
city, there is 90%.
It's a very good number.
90% of people have
3G at a given time.
So I was talking about these
numbers before in a conference.
I asked people when was the
last time you have seen Edge
on your phone?
You don't do that.
You never get it.
And someone replied
me on Twitter.
You asked me last
time I had Edge?
It's here at Droidcon
San Francisco.
So even if you're
in San Francisco,
this is sometimes what you get.
It happens because
it's very hard
to have a good coverage
for populated areas.
And it doesn't end
up working well.
So how do we fix this?
Cache, right?
Everybody does this.
You use whatever
networking library.
It catches your data,
you cache your images.
You are good, right?
No.
So we'll look at an
example about that.
They say I have this application
showing the news from sharks,
Bay area team.
So I click on the news.
I read the news.
It's all looking fine.
And then I see this.
How does this happen?
Because I did go somewhere
else, I used my phone.
I'm out-of-network.
I come back to that page.
The [? data ?] was
killed, restarted.
Hey, you never faced that
page because you only
faced the list of news,
but you never faced that
particularly news page.
Because you did not
cache it properly,
you show a loading
bar to the user.
Although you have the data, you
have a [? ACTP ?] cache that
has that news item, but you
cannot show it to the user.
That's very sad.
That should not happen.
So [? learning ?] [INAUDIBLE]
caching is not enough.
If you're caching, you
should be catching your data.
So now we say, OK.
Hopefully [INAUDIBLE]
we agree on we should
embrace the next billion users.
And how do we do that?
This is always a
question that comes on.
And I always put the slide.
Which architecture I choose?
Every other day, there's
a new architecture article
on the internet.
It's crazy.
Everybody [? puts on ?]
something new.
This architecture,
that architecture.
I have no idea
which one to choose.
But the actually thing
is it doesn't matter.
Who cares which
architecture you use?
Your user doesn't care.
It's good for you.
You should.
It is good for you to
scale their application,
have it stable, test it well.
But your users have no
idea what you are using.
All they care about is
their user experience.
So this is what should be
on your mind every time
you write some code.
So what to do.
There's two main
things you need to do.
First, your application
should work offline.
Think about you're writing
an app for a desktop.
10 years, 15 years ago when
there was usually no network.
Think when you're writing it
up, plan everything that way.
So your application should
always work offline.
Should never require network.
And you optimize for
the bad networks,
because even if
you have network,
it's not necessarily
a good network.
I know on your
desk in your office
is usually a good
network, but that's
not what your users have.
So you need to think about them.
OK.
So let's start with
offline applications.
So what do I mean
by offline apps?
The major thing you
need to be careful about
is removing network from
your user experience.
So when a user is interacting
with their application,
hopefully that should never,
ever be a network [INAUDIBLE]
in that [? flaw. ?] Well, if you
are doing your login page, yes.
But there's only a few
times it's mandatory.
Usually it's optional.
So let's look at an app.
There's a dating app.
So there's a guy.
And now you click
on the Like button,
because you want to like-- and
you're seeing a model dialog.
Liking Joe.
I told you to like Joe.
I know.
Yes, you'll do that.
Why do you have to
block me for that?
Don't do that.
This is so unnecessary.
User doesn't need
to know about that.
OK.
So we say remove that.
Don't bug the user about this.
And if you very
briefly-- [INAUDIBLE]
if you look at the application,
what happens there is you
click on the button.
It goes [INAUDIBLE]
[? presenter ?]
view controller, whatever
you choose to use.
And then it calls the network.
When the network
decides to come back,
you get it off
the modern dialog.
But who cares?
User doesn't even understand.
Like my mom doesn't really
understand that there's
a network request
[? somewhere. ?]
She doesn't know
what network is.
Get [? rid ?] of it.
So [? instead, ?] do
something in model.
Like model your data
locally so that when
the user clicks
[? the ?] button,
you just update the model.
Your mark it as [? liked, ?]
[? they ?] [? save ?] 100
milliseconds, 200 milliseconds.
It comes when you
update the [? view. ?]
Then your model tells
it to the network.
Hey, there's a change
out here locally.
Can you apply it to the server?
And the server comes back.
You refresh your [? view ?]
again because now we
know you really change it.
So if you implemented it this
way, it will look like this.
You tap on the button.
There is some sort of indication
that user receives the feedback
instantly.
And then when you finally
synchronize it, it turns red.
So it's important that you
give a feedback to the user
so they understand
something has changed.
And now you [? finally also let
them in. ?] And users learn
this.
And this is what we call a
responsive user experience.
So look at the same
application again.
I tap on it.
Oh, it's yellow.
Nice.
I know something is happening.
It received my tap.
So I go back.
There's other people.
I tap someone else again.
You go here.
Nice.
It's still doing something.
It's consistent.
It's good.
OK, I did that again.
Another use case.
And I go to this page like
I'm just reading news, right?
I stay there
[? while I'm doing ?] something
else.
And then Droid decides
to kill the application
because we needed memory.
And time passes.
I come back to the application.
And bang.
I don't see it anymore.
There was yellow.
I put some
information-- like this
is [INAUDIBLE] for the user.
You put some comment.
You [? can't ?] make
this not there anymore.
Now you have no idea
what happened there.
Did it post?
Did it not post?
What happened?
Is a buggy app?
So you don't want to do this.
And now how do we fix this?
So in the previous
one [? where ?]
we said the view
controller calls the model.
Model calls the network.
OK, let's improve
this little a bit.
Introduce something--
call it application logic,
and make the model persistent.
It's very important.
You should definitely
use [? Eskilight, ?]
use [INAUDIBLE].
Use whatever you want we.
We don't care.
But use persistent data storage.
So when the application logic
does any network request,
it always updates
the persistent model.
And then this fetches
an event, or you
might be using [INAUDIBLE].
Again, we don't care.
[INAUDIBLE]
And the view shows the
state on the model.
There are two
important parts here.
The model should be persistent,
and the view should always
reflect what is in the model.
So you don't just go and change
the bottom to selected state
while you try to
make a web request.
Don't do that.
Update the model, let
the view refresh itself.
Because when you
do this-- the user
clicks click-- you tell
their application logic,
I want to send a like.
That updates the model.
Model says, I have changed.
Or the application logic
says, I have change.
And your [INAUDIBLE], if user
is there, are like, all right.
I should refresh myself
because the data I'm displaying
has changed.
So you go there.
It refreshes [INAUDIBLE].
This is when it is yellow
because [? there's ?] panic.
It's not synced yet.
And now, when the
application logic finally
syncs it-- maybe three
days later, who cares--
it updates the model again.
And if you're
really still there,
it's going to refresh itself.
The [INAUDIBLE] is
you write these views.
They try to represent what's
in the model and nothing else.
Of course, some [? transient, ?]
temporary UI states.
So we look at the
application again.
We go there, and there
was a profile you see.
You go back.
You go to the other profile.
You're using the
application for a while.
And then what happens is you
go back to this list again,
and there's a loading.
I was in the application
two minutes ago.
I saw that list.
There is no way you are
loading that list because I
know the list is there.
So what went wrong here?
So you saw this happening.
Every time you go into your IU,
you fetch the list of users,
right?
You fetch the data,
if the user liked it.
So this is your
background thread pull.
You keep [? consuming ?]
[? these things. ?] You have
multiple workers.
So [? all ?] [? you do ?]
is refreshing user data from
network.
The other one is they
got [? big ?] stuff.
Sends the user stats.
And you went back to the UI, you
want to read the list of users
from the disk.
So you plant the right way.
You are trying to
load it from the disk.
But the problem
is your background
turns are busy trying to
make a network request.
This is so bad because
you know disk is there.
You know you won't
be able to access it.
But the network, you don't know.
And you're making the
user wait for no reason.
And the solution for
this is very simple.
You just save different queues.
For different type,
[? you want to ?] [? save ?]
different queues.
Well, you cannot just create
a queue for every type
of [? run. ?] But usually,
at least you should have one
for your network related stuff,
and one for your local access.
Even for local access,
you'll probably just use
a loader or an async task.
[? They weren't ?] fast enough,
because those things are like
100, 200 milliseconds.
300 milliseconds.
Very fast.
So once we do this is we
add these tasks because we
want to get data, they get
consumed in different queues.
So even if the network is slow,
locally, everything is working.
This is what we
call-- application
should work offline.
Everything just works.
And then you're trying
to sync it later on.
Of course, it's not
always everything.
Whatever.
So look at the other section.
How do you optimize
for the next billion?
And the next billion
looks like this.
So this is 101.
You need to translate
your application.
If you want people to use it in
the other areas of the world,
you want it to be translated.
So you translate
the application.
You translate your assets
because you have text there,
and you also translate
your in-app purchases
so that they can spend money.
But actually, this is
not completely true.
Translating is not enough.
That's is not the right word.
The right thing you
should do is localize.
So localize your application.
Don't just translate
it because let's say
you have an application
about their family.
Communicating with
their kids, whatever.
On the Play Store
page, if you're
an American family
in the United States,
put an Indonesian
family in Indonesia.
And if you're in China,
put a Chinese family.
You should localize your assets
also within the application
because this what will
make sense to that user.
Every culture has
their differences.
And if you want to make
best of localization,
this is what you
should be doing.
And the other thing
is text-free layouts.
[INAUDIBLE] you can do this.
It's really useful.
For example, if you're
a messaging app,
if you just want to say
sent, don't say sent.
Put a check mark.
[INAUDIBLE] very well.
Or if it is read, put
double check marks.
This helps you, first, you
don't need to translate it.
It's fairly global.
Your users learn it, and even
if your application is not
messaging something
else-- the literacy rate
may not be very
good in that area--
this will help more users be
able to use your application.
Another example, if you don't
need Wi-Fi don't say no Wi-Fi.
Just put this.
They learn.
People learn these things.
And multiple applications
use the same icons.
And if you use the
material team and stuff,
and user lands on
your application,
they actually know it.
They get the [INAUDIBLE].
This is very important.
The other thing is about
adaptive content fetching.
So let's say this is an
application that shows photos.
And this is the same UI.
Pretty much looks the same.
Of course the one on the
right is kind of low quality.
But the one on the
left is 100% JPEG,
and the right is 10% JPEG.
It is almost 1/10 of it in
terms of size, and it looks OK.
Now of course you don't
want to show a lower quality
image to your users, but you
need to think about-- they
either see the
lower quality image,
or they see a blank screen.
There's a big difference
between seeing a blank screen
and a low quality image.
And bonus points, you
can re-fetch the content.
So you realize the
network is not very good.
Your fetch the
lower quality image.
And once you figure
out somewhere else,
the network recovers.
You refresh those images,
especially if it is free.
You should do that.
[INAUDIBLE] the connectivity
[? manager ?] API actually
tells you if the network
is metered or not.
So I want to give some
examples what we do
at Google about these things.
For example, if you're using
Google+, in the settings menu,
there is a way to say,
OK, conserve data usage.
Now, if you're even living
in the United States,
you probably don't
really check because you
have unlimited data.
But the rest of the people
pay premiums for their data.
So they're very, very
conscious about it.
So you put the
settings like that.
And in Google+, these
are what we actually do.
If the network is fast, we
fetch a high quality JPEG.
As the network goes slower,
we go lower, or maybe
[? version ?].
So we show a version.
And it's like, instead
of seeing a blank screen,
user sees some data.
We help them see their data.
It's a [? win-win. ?] And they
get a better user experience.
And we also educate the users.
This is also important.
It's like, what does it
mean to conserve data?
Why don't you always do it?
Like, why are you
wasting my data?
And if your users click
on there, we explain them,
this is what it
means to save data.
Another part is
adaptive behavior.
Now, it's very common
in applications
to have auto playing games,
or auto playing videos.
What you should do
is, at this point,
my user is showing my feed.
Is the network fast?
If the network is
fast, it's cool.
Just go auto play the video.
But if the network is
slow, don't do that.
Just put a Play button.
Don't waste their
network just because they
may want to watch that video.
That's a bad thing
for your users.
And I have good network here,
so will play this video.
Yes, good girl.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, so, for example, this
is what we do on YouTube.
In YouTube, if you go
to Quality Settings,
there is an option
that says Auto.
That's actually what it does.
By checking the network
quality, we adjust your bitrate.
And I'm sure you are so used
to this behavior you maybe
don't even notice.
But it takes time to implement.
But the good news is the
ExoPlayer library from Google
already support DASH
and smooth streaming.
All you have to do
is use this library
and let it handle these
different network protocols.
Of course, also, your server
side needs to support it.
Was not hard.
It's easy.
It's important.
OK.
Come on.
All right.
So this is another use case.
Look at Uncle Bob.
So this guy goes to
work every morning,
takes the bus, maybe Google
bus, reads his news on the bus.
Does the same thing
on the way back.
This happens all the time.
But what also happens
all the time is this.
He's seeing a
loading [? dollop ?]
when he tries to read his news
because there's like another 60
people in the same bus trying
to use the same internet
connection.
And there's a lot
of other cars there.
It's really like the
network gets congested,
and no one gets a
good experience.
How can we fix this?
Well, the good news
is that this guy
goes to work almost the
same time every morning.
So he wakes up at 6:30.
No brainer, set an alarm, right?
We can set an alarm to
prepare the content for him.
And also maybe, he leaves
the work at, like, 5:30
every night.
Let me set an alarm for
that and prepare the content
so that they get some content
when they open the application.
And the way we can do this
is, we have the alarmManager
clause that will help you
wake up your application
every morning, 6:30, so you
can pre-fetch your content.
So let's say we implemented it.
We are good, right?
So all these users
have a good experience.
Every morning, 6:30,
they get the latest news,
and they are happy.
But then we get more users.
And more users make
this request at 6:30.
And then this is what happens.
Your cloud goes down.
And you know what comes up
when your cloud goes down?
Your system admin.
That guy slept at like
4:30 AM in the morning.
You woke him up at
6:30 with a pager.
Why?
Because you just made [? that ?]
[? because ?] 6:30 from every
single client.
And actually, it's a real story.
We once seen a bug request
because from a provider.
They said, there's a
bug with Android phones.
Every morning, at this time,
we're getting so many request.
Turns out, it was an
application like this.
So we don't do that.
How do we fix this?
Super simple.
So instead of just waking up
at 6:30, you randomize it.
Wake up between 6:00 and 7:00.
And then you wake
up each application
in that random time.
And then you're
server admin is happy.
But then we are unhappy.
Using AlarmManager, seriously?
2016.
Come on.
How do we do this?
We do this with JobScheduler.
Or you can use JSON network
manager for the older API
versions.
So we wanted to do
this with JobScheduler.
You create a job, you say,
OK, this is my service.
You say, we want the
unmetered network.
There is no reason
to cache the data
if user is going to pay for it.
And then we say, OK, start
the earliest, around 6:30.
And then make it only
if the device is idle.
And you say, if it
was only charging--
these are all optional things.
You say, all right, these are
all optional things that you
cannot [? depend on in ?]
your use case.
So what does this
overrideDeadline mean?
So the idea here is that,
let's say we have this thing,
and user forgot to
charge their phone.
So it will wake
up in the morning.
But what will happen
is the job will be just
waiting there, sitting idle.
Maybe user will go to
work, and then they
will plug their phone.
And then we will
fetch the content.
It's already passed, like,
we missed the deadline.
Why would you do this?
So we tell the job
scheduler, hey,
if you cannot do this
until 7:30, wake me up.
So what we can do is,
when the job is started,
you can simply check, OK,
did I get the deadline?
Did the deadline expire?
If the deadline expired, if
that's why I was woken up.
This will [INAUDIBLE].
Is the connection unlimited?
If it is not, just
return false, I
don't want to run
this job anymore.
Or if you can say something
like, if the battery is
charging, or is,
like, at least 75%,
otherwise I will
not run this job.
So this completely
depends on your use case.
But you get the idea.
Like, thing a [? beat, ?] try
to be total about these things.
I think we provide enough main
APIs on the framework side
to be able to
implement these things.
And it's not hard.
And in turn, your user receives
a really, really good user
experience.
This is important.
So, for example, in YouTube,
you can go ahead and download
a video for offline so that,
you know, you do it at home,
you watch the TV
series, you download it,
and while in the box,
you can watch it.
Or in Maps, like,
recently, I was on vacation
outside the country.
And I just downloaded
the area on Google Maps.
And even though I
didn't have data there,
I could use my
phone to navigate.
It was so nice.
So these are like little
things that makes a huge user
experience difference.
Or, for example, another
example of pre-fetching,
this is slightly different, but
this is what we do in Google+.
So whenever we think
that there are new posts,
we show a little touch button
that you can tap to refresh.
So in there, what happens
behind the scenes is we detected
our new post, we let the user
know, and if the user Tabs,
we are going to go ahead
and fetch the content
and then refresh the UI.
But we changed
this a little bit.
This is what we did.
When we did a new post now, we
actually go ahead and fetch it
because users in the application
we detected [INAUDIBLE],
they want to see it.
We are fairly comfortable
that they want that content.
So we fetch it for them.
And then we let the user know
that there is new content.
But we don't just
refresh it because they
might be doing something else.
And it will be a
bad user experience.
Instead we just notify the
user that there is new content.
And if they tap, we
will refresh the data.
Now, the difference between
these two user experience flaws
is the first one takes
around three seconds.
The second one
takes 0.3 seconds.
This is almost 10x.
There is a 9x difference--
you just change
the order of two operations.
A huge user
experience improvement
with very, very little
effort is important.
But if you're
doing pre-fetching,
it's a very dangerous thing.
It's really good for users.
But it might be also real bad.
So you need to be careful.
First thing you should
be doing is balance
for the available storage.
Just don't fill up their phone.
Especially in the
rest of the world,
like, the phones
have lower memory.
So you shouldn't
be filling it out
with your pre-fetch content.
Or, if you're going to fetch
some data that's expensive,
let the user know.
I want to do this update.
Provide them with
settings for these things.
These people are
really, really--
they care about their data.
They're really, really into it.
So you should give them options.
And they will use them.
The other part is-- so I always
get this thing like, oh, now
the Android devices have 2,
3 gigabytes of memory-- we
don't need to care about it.
Wrong.
It's not like that
because first, the screens
got a lot bigger, so we need to
use a lot more graphic memory.
Your [? SS ?] get a lot
more higher quality.
Those things are wasting
a lot more memory
than they used to do before.
Plus we try to run a lot more
many applications because it's
the best for the user.
So always measure your memory.
And, like in the latest
versions of Android studio,
this is so easy, you
just step on a button.
I remember, before, you
will need to use, like, get
the memory down from
DDMS, and then [INAUDIBLE]
convert it, and then
open it in [? Eclipse ?].
It was a mess.
Now, in Android Studio,
just click on a button,
it takes the
[INAUDIBLE] for you.
I opens in this nice UI.
And you know.
There is usual suspects there.
You just click on that.
We will show you
all instances of it.
You can check, OK, why
am retaining this object?
And the coolest thing,
I love this thing,
you can just right click on
the selected item, View Bitmap.
Like how cool is that what?
Do you know what
you have linked?
This is so much faster than
what you were able to do before.
So we're always spending time
on making these tools better,
and you should take
advantage of them.
So also in N, so you can have
seen, like, in marshmallow,
in N, we're spending a lot
of time in battery life.
This is very important for
us, overall system health.
And we cannot do this
without your help.
So in N, we also
introduced this new feature
called Data Saver where
user can say, you know what?
I want to limit application
data for the background apps.
They don't get any data unless
the network is [? unlimited. ?]
But if you're a
good application,
user might whitelist you.
So if you implemented
it properly,
they will whitelist you, so
you will get the data while
your competitor doesn't.
And it only works
in metered networks.
So we only block you if
we have a reason to do so.
So how will you use it?
So the connectivity manager
now has this new API.
We can say, hey, is that
active network metered?
And if it is metered, you can
get the background status,
like you know if it is enabled,
or if you are whitelisted,
or we are disabled.
So the idea is that, even if
the user put Data Saver on,
but you're whitelisted,
you should still
be cautious about, OK, I don't
want to spend too much data.
Hey, I have, like,
user [INAUDIBLE] data.
That is just [INAUDIBLE].
You can send it later.
You don't need to send it now.
So going to some more
offline use cases.
And I want you to like
start thinking about, OK,
how can I make my
application more offline?
So this one use case, the first
time we give this talk a year
ago people say, OK, like if
were a commercial app, right,
there's a place where
people buy products,
I cannot make it offline.
Which is true, you cannot make
it offline because the price
changes.
There's no way you'll tell them,
hey, you bought this for $500,
and then, one day later,
you charge them $700.
You cannot do that.
That would be rude.
But there are still
things you can do.
Your application, like
product information,
when you buy something, when
I'm going to buy something,
[? most likely, ?] I go to the
same page again, and again,
and again.
This will happen.
This is a user behavior.
So optimize for that.
Keep the user data.
Let them search.
I will probably search
for the same products.
Let them do a local search.
Remember when we
talk about having
a proper persistent model?
It helps you here because you
can let them search locally
but still let them know that,
I'm showing local results only.
If they go to the product page,
show some sort of animation
saying that, you cannot
buy this right now,
I'm fetching the price.
Your designer will give
you a better asset.
And then, when the price
comes, you show it to them.
So you don't block the user.
But, for important
data, you just
don't show it, or
show it grayed out.
But think about this.
Another example is
a messaging app.
So they say, Jenny and Michael.
So this is a couple.
Jenny says, OK,
let's go to a movie.
Michael says, sure, let's
watch "The Big Short."
Jenny says, fine,
pick me up at 7:00.
And OK, we'll meet at 7:00.
But around 630 Michael realizes
that, hey, his Dog is sick.
He doesn't want to
leave the dog home.
So he says, hey,
Jenny, my dog is sick.
How about you come over?
We hang out at home?
It's all [? good ?].
Unless, you know,
the message isn't
going be sent for no reason.
Failed.
Tap to try again.
So as a developer,
I let the user know.
You're actually not done.
Because Michael,
you know, he wants
to call his vet to get
some tips and stuff.
So he already left
the application.
So Michael did not know that
you couldn't send the message.
That Michael could not know that
you didn't send the message.
Jenny never saw the message.
And this is Jenny's heart.
It's broken because of you.
[INAUDIBLE] OK.
We have a solution.
What could you do?
You can do something
better, right?
It's important.
If you're [? the ?]
dating profile,
and you couldn't send it
to the user now, it's fine.
Like, it's not that important.
This is a messaging application.
It's an instant
messaging application.
You have some responsibilities.
So if you couldn't
send the message,
and you know user didn't
see it, let them know.
Show a notification.
Because you already know that
user is not in your activity.
You already know that they
did not see the message.
So instead, you
show a notification.
Michael calls his girlfriend.
And they're happy
couple, thanks to you.
And another thing that
you could, like, further
improve the user experiences,
you can always let them know.
Like if you're in the
screen they're messaging,
if you know there's no internet
connection, just put it.
By the way, if you're listening
for internet connection
in [? an ?] or [? all ?], you
only receive that broadcast
if you are the
front application.
Don't register for that
broadcast in your manifest.
[? It's ?] just stopped working.
So you can try.
It's not going to work.
But your application,
you can still
use the Connectivity Manager
and register that broadcast
programatically.
So as another example, if you
have a TV schedule application,
of course they cannot
watch TV offline.
But you can do some stuff.
You can let them click on a
button and schedule an alarm.
There's still
things that you can
do because you can implant
all of this within the device
without [INAUDIBLE]
network communication.
So the idea is that
if, you start thinking
about what can I do offline?
What I can I do offline?
You will find really,
really good use cases.
And it's going to
differentiate your application.
So even though we are talking
about this [? talk, ?]
you say it's like next
billion users offline,
this actually helps your
users all around the world.
It's not only for them.
So I want to quickly
go through this.
It's like, OK, I'll say,
you synchronize the data.
You update the persistent model,
and now you synchronize data.
How do you do this?
So luckily, scientist has
we're working on this problem.
We don't have to solve it.
There's something
operational transformer,
like things like
Google Docs uses.
Or there's conflict
free replication.
There's a bunch of
things I don't know.
There's a lot of [? articles ?].
But you don't need them.
What we apply is the
Pareto Principle.
We will do the 20% of the work.
We'll get the 80%
of the benefits.
And we'll run away.
For example, if you
have a post, or user,
there's something you can like.
And when user likes it,
you mark it as liked.
You update the model.
But what happens is, next time
like, that was another request
running, and it fetches
the list we're posting at.
It just overrides what
you have put there.
That's a bad problem.
How do you solve this?
Very easy.
You add another field that
you only modify locally.
So it's yours.
I call this, like, local here.
So when you want to check
if user liked a post,
all you do is, hey,
you update that field.
When fetch the feed,
it doesn't override
because that field doesn't
exist on the server side.
And if you want to get,
when you are putting the UI,
if you want to check
that the user liked this,
well it's very simple.
You check if there's
a local value.
Show it.
Otherwise, use
the value that you
[INAUDIBLE] from the server.
This is very simple thing,
super easy to implement.
And it gives you
most of the benefit.
So another example, let's
say you're fetching posts,
some posts have been
deleted on the server.
Tell your server guys.
Let them send you the
list of deleted posts.
It's so easy for them to do.
And this way, you can
locally cache everything,
[? or ?] show
everything locally,
and if something has been
deleted on the server,
you will eventually
get notified about it.
And you will update
your local [? later ?].
This is very easy
for them to do.
So if you get
another example, you
could be sending
the server, hey, I
have the post between
8 and 31 when you make
a call to get the new posts.
Your [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever, right?
And now the server can send
you which items from that range
has been deleted.
I know it's sometimes hard to
convince your backend people,
like there's a
[? clash ?], everybody
wants the other
people to do the work.
And there's this thing like,
hey, I have a perfect REST API.
So you make 25 requests
just to fetch a feed.
Don't let them do that.
Fight for it.
It's important that they
provide you the right APIs
for your application.
So there's another case here.
Like I've been trying to
update the profile page.
And I have two
different clients.
One of them changes
the federal color.
The other one changes the name.
And I get a conflict.
How do you solve these
kind of conflicts?
Add a version.
Now your date is versioned.
So when you make a request,
[? client ?] says, OK,
[? change the favorite ?] color
to this one on top of version
10.
And then the server can
say, OK, since this version,
I can apply this
[? diff ?] and do it.
Or decide whatever
you want to do.
Maybe you don't want
them to do that.
The thing is, it will
happen very rarely,
and you will be
handling that case.
So these won't
override each other.
And if you start versioning your
objects, your value objects,
you get this nice
thing where, hey, you
made a request of fetch posts.
Some of them were updated.
Server already knows.
You told the server,
I have these items
with these versions.
The stuff that has been
changed, they could tell,
hey, hey, these are the
posts that have been updated.
And here is their new data.
In one request, you
get all of the diff.
Again, I'm not telling
you to do things this way.
This is just a way
of doing things.
It's very simple.
And it is effective.
So if you want to read
more about this topic,
you can go learn about, like,
multiversion concurrence
and control.
It's widely used in databases.
Like maybe some really,
really important,
like learn about
operational transfer
if this is really,
really important
for you do you, like, multiple
clients changing the same data.
So these are solved problems.
You just need to
go and check them.
So it's not hard.
OK, I will go to some quickly
tips and tricks with a bite
size information.
As I said before, when
we talk about network,
design your API for your client.
[INAUDIBLE] like I have
a perfect REST API.
No, that doesn't matter!
The perfect API is the one
that my user experience
fits the best.
This is what you want.
So do it.
Tell them to do it for you.
But your API should be
for your application.
And whatever you can do on the
server, do it on the server.
Like if they can pass metadata,
anything that will help you,
do it there.
Because it is much easier to
scale than the tiny device
you have on your pocket.
And one more thing you do
is batch your requests.
Now again and again, we say,
battery life is very important.
Date is very important.
If you batch your
requests, the battery life
will improve a lot.
JobScheduler already
does it for you.
So just use JobScheduler or
[? GCI Network Manager. ?] You
will be a good citizen.
We will love you.
It's good things.
So for example, this an
example of a bad API.
This is a terrible API.
It gives me a user, a
name, and a photoURL.
I have no idea what that
photoURL represents.
You put through it in
a [? stagnant ?] grid.
It recycled the view.
When you fetch the
photo, grid starts
moving because you didn't
know how big the image is.
You just put something
random there,
and the image turned out
to be a real weird one.
So your UI had to reschedule.
It's terrible for the user.
And it's very easy to fix.
Tell your server to send you the
width and height of the image,
so you can put the placeholder.
Like anything in
RecyclerView loves this.
Like when they come
[? online, ?] they
want to have the final size.
If your server sends it to
you, you have the final size.
You can even send the palette.
It's also very easy to
calculate on the server side
instead of doing
it on the device.
They send you the
palette of the picture.
So while you are
fetching the picture,
instead of just
showing the gray box,
you show another box that has
the same background color,
so you can like easily
transform to the new one.
This improves user experience.
It's very important.
So to sum up everything,
the main goal
here is you [? architecture ?]
your application
for the user experience.
They can be in United States.
They can be Indonesia,
China, doesn't matter.
The important thing is
their user experiences.
It's your responsibility.
Have a real local model.
Just don't keep
things in a hash maps.
Put them on to the SQL
[INAUDIBLE] realm, whatever
you prefer, we don't care.
But put it on disk.
And when you write your
application don't think, OK,
now I get this data from the
server, and I update this UI,
a user clicks on this, I
make this other request.
Don't do that.
Think about, I have the
data on the disk, that's
what I show to the
user, my user reacts.
I have some logic to update
the data on the disk,
and I show it all the time.
And some other
application logic that
tries to synchronize the
data with the server.
It makes it a lot easier.
And decouple.
Like, you should
decouple these things.
The part that's related
to the UI, and the disk,
they know each other.
You have an application logic
that talks to the network.
When you decouple things, it
makes it a lot easier to test.
But don't overdo it.
Like when I see, like, there
is more powerful architectures,
and people, hey, I
create an interface,
an interface for the
factories, and the interface
of the factory factories.
It's like, don't do that.
This is still a phone.
If you look at the
framework code,
we still write it as
we write C. You don't
have to write it like that.
Use [INAUDIBLE],
whatever, do it.
Use it, if it makes
your application better.
But don't over-architect.
It's still a mobile phone.
We are trying to run
many, many, applications
on the same device.
And even if the device say
four cores, eight cores,
most of the time, only
one or two of those cores
are actually really
capable of doing anything.
Plus we try to keep
them [? low ?] mode
or not run them at
all, to save battery.
And act early.
This is important.
In a previous job I worked,
I [? paid ?] this [? step. ?]
if you have this kind of
technical depth, it's really,
really hard to [? pay ?].
So the sooner you
start, the better it is.
And one last note, something
to remember from this talk,
know your enemies.
Network is unreliable.
You don't want to be
doing a network request.
Every time you make
a network request,
you should feel uncomfortable,
like, ew, what's going on.
And then know your friends.
Disk is your friend.
Persists everything.
It's very reliable.
If the disk is broken, the
phone is already broken,
so you don't need
to worry about it.
So, it's your friend.
It's actually your best friend.
Thank you.